One suggestion I have is that you don't give it a name.
What's the name? It's
such a fun time for these six people to get together, so I
want to make it special.
Give this moment, this space, this relationship a name.
[Music] Is it
weird? It's not weird. It's
full of romance, but that's okay too. [
Music] I don't think so.
Even if someone suddenly says something like that to me,
everyone will come to me and pull me out.  May I
ask if you could help me? They put their
engines together and
each sticks out their swords straight out.
This shape overlaps each other.
In my hometown, we used to call it the prefectural flower, or kenka. It's a
shape that represents the bond between the uninhabited.
Well, it's similar to this in Asia.  I swear friendship, no, I
don't swear anything, I
just
remember the
shape of the flower that bloomed here.A
warrior uses the words to talk about the future.The only thing we
can do is to vividly imprint this present moment.No matter
how the future turns,
we will remember it.  You can never scatter the flowers that are tied here in a moment.Therefore, I
wish I could agree with that.The
Sword Flower.It's
a bit strange, but I think it's a good name.All
flowers bloom without fear of knowing.We
That's how it is.The
moments that accumulate like that are surely prouder than eternity.Pete's
face is bright red.I'm sorry for you, too.I
don't need to be able to control my feelings.If it's going to be an unforgettable moment, including this embarrassment.  Now that it's
special, from
this moment onwards,
we'll burn it into battle bullets
[Music]
So that it'll never fade